passé dans l'est et à droite et à gauche
paysage avec chou vert toile sûrs et un
point un peu large mais pas un peu large
avec le verre cassé fort longtemps un
peu le vert c'est joli ça
un peu dessus peut-être là dans
l'enfance et les rangs voici les
sans-papiers pu faire un tour doit être
caché par les arbres on va les retrouver
le côté cargo d'armes et cabinet by the
trees
un papa poule on
à découvrir juste derrière les palmiers
pour la gauche
et vous avec les mains derrière c'est
beau ça a donné comme ça boucles bert
van roekeghem mobiles-actus vois le
verre un premier à du verre dans l'image
et super saut vers pas le verre de
postes ouverts jour et c'est vachement
beau ça
c'est bof warrior un peu c'est un verre
du pacifique un peu à gauche voilà
tuvalu et va le voir de se voir arriver
le vert derrière superbe arrivée en bas
de l'image des éléphants
pendant toute la vue derrière ces pays
je ne vois pas de cul à droite se parer
fit paraître
voilà on va retrouver l'autre côté les
combattants
on les voit à travers tes jolies un
louis vuitton
ces gosses à travers les arbres la
taille de petites barbes et le verger
bénéfique et bien en bas de l'image
c'est beau c'est beau c'est bien un
ventre chemin dans le ventre et au chili
bon allez on va lancer les éléphants les
où l'arbre pour ça
et je suis là et vous on fait bien
passage derrière les arbres est plus
serré pour qu'on n'aille pas mal de tête
de l'histoire
ok
bursa ouest avec elle plus longtemps
possible en un coup r
c'est un travail que ça va puis à plus
tard travers la drees adrien joreige de
vendre en face à ces bons rails
le bus était plein de bons plans et il a
eu un fils vont être selon lui plus
visible
hélas le sport beauchamp ouais j'ai vu
dit
les foules à rouler on en aura mieux ça
vaut ne pas y aller je parle pas tenir
longtemps le plus que tout ce que je
peux non mais aussi des fascistes
ok ok pas aux fantasmes